I am very particular about time doctor
who is back so the pilot first episode
of series 10 of Doctor Who I had I'm not
going I was nervous I had some points of
concern going to this basically this
thing had two major job that I needed
this episode to do I needed it to sell
me on build was the character who I've
expressed some concerns about in the
past and it had to show me that the
doctor was still going to be fun because
there were some things said sort of in
the lead up that made me concerned that
they were going to go back more to
series 8 version of Capaldi's doctor as
opposed to series 9 series 8 he wasn't
as much fun at least I didn't think he
was so on both those counts I am very
happy bill um was sold to me on pretty
much every level she needed to be very
quickly she's got good rapport with
Capaldi I really like the dynamic with
her and nardole and the doctor it just
the nobody feels redundant and that was
another thing I've been worried about
because I really liked
nardole when he showed up in the
Christmas special so I already knew I
liked him I was afraid that adding bill
to that mix was going to throw it out of
whack but it doesn't it actually it sort
of gives me let's nardole do what he's
best at which is cousin to kind of take
one step back and just do a little bit
of commentary on it you know he's just
listening to the jeweler minute o banter
I love that I think that sort of stuff's
great and I also understand and this is
a big thing for me especially coming on
the back of Clara and me having been
very iffy about her I get the doctors
attraction to bill on numerous levels
it's explained in very simple terms when
he just said you know most people when
they see some when they hear something
they don't understand they found you
smile like great mediately I get why he
is has an attraction to her like her
mind and the way she processes so get
that right
off the bat and then I see his
interactions with nardole and I think I
can see where the doctor would want
somebody else because you know with
Naruto Liang he's nice to have around
but you know you can't you can't quite
engage him on the same level he doesn't
have the same level of curiosity you
can't you can't teach him and sort of
introducing the dynamic of the doctor
and build together as a teacher-student
relationship echoing in some ways ace a
you know was the communion of the
seventh doctor
that s the dynamic I guess it's a
dynamic that is nicely different I mean
that the doctor has taken opportunities
you know to try and educate his
companions of various points but there
has that be the fundamental basis for
the relationship I think that is a nice
thing and that I would say we haven't
really gotten in modern era and I'm down
for that
I'm kind of just going to jump all over
the place I love the setup
I love the the idea that he's just
teaching at a university ously the vault
and we have no idea what's going on with
the ball right now um you know what it
is why he's guarding it who he's
guarding it from what he's afraid of
etcetera etcetera etc but I like that
what he's found to pass the time when he
kind of can't you know just go off and
leave this thing unattended for very
long he just he just teaches and handy
he lectures about whatever he wants you
know physics is like chemistry because
of the rhymes you know that I love that
stop process and I love I think it fits
Capaldi's doctor you know he's the
professor that everyone thinks is the
coolest guy on campus I totally buy that
I buy him as and there's just so many
little touches that I love especially
about his office
I love the the jar of of sonic
screwdrivers I love that he's got a
picture of River and one and they kept
coming back to I think even more often
than River the picture of Susan of his
granddaughter that oh yes so I like
where we start from I like the
characters I like the dynamics what
about the story well
um it's fine it you know it's not
amazing it's interesting it's kind of
intriguing it leaves possibly more
questions than answers you know if
you're really a logistical nuts and
bolts kind of viewer but for me it works
and it works in the way that I think I
most good sort of stories where the plot
isn't going to be the point um you know
work well and what I say that I mean
like stories like the eleventh hours I
think is a great example because that
had to introduce Matt Smith's doctor and
Amy and you know sort of reestablish
everything so the actual plot in the
story you know dealing with Prisoner
Zero whatnot it all it had to do is be
functional because the point of the
episode was not that story that was
being told it was all the stuff that
telling the story would allow them to
communicate to the audience this is very
much in that same vein and much like the
eleventh hour it does that very well and
this story sort of focusing on Billa
I found the the puddle intriguing and
you know what I'm just going to say it I
think the use of water and the dripping
sound effect and other things I think
water was scarier than it wasn't waters
of Mars I'll just say it come at me um
but it was intriguing it was it was
nicely visual the way it worked I am
going to pick on anything like maybe
some kind of the tail end resolution you
know would bill actually touches Heather
and kind of what happens you know that
lead up to that moment in that moment in
the immediate aftermath is a little
cheesy um but that's about the only
thing I would single out as being a bit
of a weakness the plot as I said does
what it needs to do to allow you know us
as an audience to get a sense of this
dynamic so that we can get our feet and
get our grounding with these characters
and get a sense of what's going on
because that's what that's what this
episode really had to do and it does
that with aplomb so I'm I'm really
really digging this I'm going to be
really curious see where it goes
obviously you know I think the vault is
a is a nice setup and they have an
oversold it too much
I like the
of things that bill sort of immediately
grasps and sort of coming at other
things just from me she should her brain
her mind and her thought process it just
seems to be different from what we
usually get from a lot of the modern era
companions so it's just interesting you
know just the fact that took her longer
um to get what was going on with the
TARDIS I mean that and and yet the fact
that took longer didn't make her look
stupid that's that's well executed
that's well balanced so I'm really glad
Doctor Who is back and this was this was
a good start this was a good solid start
I am excited for what else we are going
to get this series and I am I'm going to
be sad that Capaldi leaves but uh this
if we can build off this initial
starting place I think this is going to
be a really nice send-off so have you
seen the pilot so what were your
thoughts on it whatever they were drop
something down in the comment let's talk
about it don't forget to like subscribe
check me out on Twitter council of geeks
give a listen to the council of geeks
podcast available on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]